any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
introduction to today's guest
who is a very very well-known scientist
a thinker
an author and that's jeremy england and
he is a rabbi and a doctor
and a professor and senior director in
artificial intelligence
at glaxo smith klein he's a principal
research scientist at georgia tech
and the former thomas and virginia cabot
career development associate professor
of physics at mit which is i understand
is a small technical college in
northeastern massachusetts in boston
he was a rhodes scholar a hertz fellow
and was named one of forbes 30 under 30
rising stars in science
and he has written this book courtesy of
basic books a renowned imprint
i believe they published the feynman
lectures right jeremy and he's joining
us today
to discuss this book but also some of
his um very provocative and very
intriguing theories this is entropy
month on the into the impossible podcast
we have jeremy as well as julian barbour
coming on
and we will have lee cronin who's a
professor in glasgow coming on talking
about life and entropy and all those
good things but
rabbi jeremy england i want to ask you
as i ask all my guests who have
sat down written books and shared their
intellectual musings with the universe i
like to ask every
author to do what you're never supposed
to do which is to judge a book by its
cover
and i'm going to ask you
rabbi england if i may call you jeremy
this book where do you get the title and
the cover design from
so the title of the book comes from the
end of one of the later chapters um and
it is a concept that
i try to develop over the course of the
book it's
in a sense maybe i don't know what i
want to call it the punch line but
the idea is to try to understand
self-organization
that starts to look lifelike that starts
to have different features of its
behavior resemble what we think of as
being distinctive of life
and part of the point is that this has
to do with how energy is flowing through
the matter
and why the flow of energy
is keeping it in a special shape instead
of sort of smashing it to smithereens or
randomizing it in the way that other
kinds of energy flow would tend to do
and so
there's this question of what it means
to be sort of
both on fire and and also still kind of
sustained by that energy flow instead of
torn apart by it as you might expect if
you saw something on fire
and then of course also partly the book
um is a contemplation of passages in the
hebrew bible that are connected with
some of these concepts to kind of put it
in a poetic or philosophic frame and so
the idea of the burning bush that moses
encounters um
when he's in the wilderness uh is very
much that same idea right something a
living thing that's on fire but not
consumed um and so the title then
comes from there and then the picture
you know was was i think some very
uh nice cover art that someone developed
in basic that is around that concept
because there's the fire and there's a
serpent and
so the it sort of both looks like
a flame and a serpent and and you kind
of go from there
very good
very good yes and i
love the biblical passages throughout
the uh throughout the discussion i've
had on more uh sort of christian
apologists or christian supporters of
intelligent design which you do comment
on in the book maybe we'll get to that
but the uh the preponderance of people
on the show have not been uh a jewish or
ordination although one of my close
friends and mentors is rabbi david wolpe
of sinai temple los angeles who's this
brilliant thinker and intellectual i'm
sure he'll be interested in this as well
he has his own podcast um so we've had
on a lot of christian perspectives on
the podcast and i thought you know
because i am obviously a practicing jew
my audience knows that
i am not a prostitizer i do not believe
that it is permissible according to
judaic religion to go out and try to
convert people although many of the
people that i have talked to
in the course of the podcast especially
in the christian realm or been
associated with people like william lane
craig and maybe even james tour and
other people that that are very famous
intellectuals that do christian
apologetics there always seems to me
jeremy to be kind of an interesting line
that i find uh very challenging to me as
a person of faith but not necessarily as
devout as as they are or maybe even as
you are and that is you know there
always seems to be a notion of
everything that had a beginning had a
beginner
so the universe must have had a beginner
and then the next step is that there
must be some entity that created the
beginning of the universe and that
entity sustains us and is personally
related to us in other words the god
that created the universe has a personal
relationship with us has demands of us
and then and it always goes from there
to jesus
uh with most of the scholars that i've
had on and of course i as a practicing
jew cannot accept jesus as the
fulfillment of the role of mashiach or
messiah as fulfilled or pro you know
discussed in tanak and in the talmud and
other places but how do you approach
that you know kind of the fact that we
are maybe fellow travelers to some
extent intellectually with people who
support the notion of a god or godlike
force maybe
you know present at the only at the
beginning maybe continually present how
do you trace along with that but not um
not you know travel along with them but
not necessarily come to the same
conclusion that jesus must be therefore
the personal instantiation of god for us
sure so
i i think that clearly when talking
about these kinds of theological
questions people come to a lot of
different conclusions and even within
different religious systems
the
same uh
kinds of ideas can sound very different
depending on who's talking about them so
i'll start by just kind of speaking
from my own perspective of
interpretation which i don't want to
claim
summarizes everything that every
theological thinker even in judaism has
said you know over the last however many
thousands of years
um
i think for me
the whole
approach to talking about
the beginnings of the universe and the
existence of god and those kinds of
questions people tend to get very
wrapped up and
they they don't fit to me
in how it seems to me that the torah the
the
sacred texts that's at the core of the
jewish tradition is submitting itself
for consideration i don't think
it's trying to be a text that puts
forward
a testable claim about a sort of fact
about the universe where you could go
out with your measuring device and sort
of say
is there in fact a creator here or not
you know i finally figured out whether
the statements here in this document are
true or false i think it's it's very
different than that
it's more like a choice on the part of a
person who chooses to be party to an
agreement
in how they interpret experience and act
in the world
and it's it's like a playbook for that
it's a way of talking about the world
that helps frame your thinking and helps
you have a language for describing what
you're doing and why you're doing it and
and and the thing i think is so
important about that is it means that
contrary to the more sort of hellenistic
idea the more greek idea that i think
ends up very heavily
influencing
christian theology and then
it's devolutions even to come back and
touch post-medieval jewish theology as a
result um
we're not talking about
is something there or isn't it there i
if i read the talmud if i read the the
the hebrew scriptures like the hebrew
bible the writings of the hebrew
prophets and the torah
what it seems to me is it's more like
making a recommendation about
a procedure for interpreting experience
meaning
the universe does exist we have
experience here we have a world here to
understand and there are different
interpretive frames that you can put on
that experience you can talk about it in
different ways you could try to describe
it and make sense of it in different
terms and one way you could do that is
by relating to it as a personality
relating to it
as
a
an interlocutor you know someone with
whom you're capable of having dialogue
um and that's just kind of a proposal in
a sense uh the the puzzle of the
universe's existence is always a
philosophical uh sort of conundrum of
why it's there where you can always
start by saying well the answer is it's
the expression of the will of a certain
personality and then the question is
how far does that interpretive frame get
you like is it predictive is it
effective in explaining to you what
happens to you and your nation or
whoever in the world um does it end up
giving you you know the power to make
sense of you know and find coherence in
the sets of events that you observe and
i think to that degree the hard part is
not convincing someone to try that out i
think that this sort of the difficult
claim the one that's not at all obvious
is true from this perspective of judaism
in terms of what's being claimed there
is that it is the god of the hebrew
bible who is that personality like it
would be much easier to just say i'll
try to relate to the universe as a
personality and see how that goes
but why would it be that that
personality
has very particular expectations right
like don't wear wool with
linen in one woven fabric if you belong
to this particular nation that descends
from abraham isaac and jacob and has
this particular covenant that shouldn't
be obvious right you're not going to get
that from trying to
find personality in the statistics of
experience
so i think that's the the real hard part
the the challenge
that shouldn't be easy for anyone and it
is kind of the lifelong struggle of
someone who's trying to make sense of
the torah it's not
can one find a personality in
the universe and kind of have an
operating system that assumes that
there's a kind of a creative will behind
the events you experience it's more like
and why would i think that that
personality is the same one that makes
very specific demands that were given to
moses at a particular time that have
real details to them and real content to
them like don't murder and don't light
fires on saturdays and don't eat pigs
and things like that as they pertain to
not all of humanity entirely but in some
instances just specific rules for a
specific subset of humanity you know
it's a very
not obvious thing and so i think that's
where i'd start that off
yeah i mean i always encapsulate it as
you know it's not as important to you
know ask if i believe in god but if god
believes in me because that would
presuppose both his existence and his uh
concern with me
as a uh individual personal god i think
we see that in the caduce that we do on
shabbat where you know partially we
testify to god's creating the universe
which is kind of the universal literally
universal god that's kind of my my
purview in this conversation and then
there's the
and then there's the personal god side
where he liberated us from egypt and the
house of bondage and those two aspects
says dual sides of a god who exists to
create the universe for everybody not
just for the jews and then a specific as
i said instantiation of that god i think
that's you know very fascinating maybe
it's paradigmatic and so forth uh but
from there you know from very believing
um uh you know kind of jews and
christians who we we both have you know
admiration for uh and and and can
consent with in many aspects of religion
i want to turn to the question of why
are so many why are there so many jewish
nobel prize winners and why are almost
all of them atheists uh if not devoutly
so
what have you this is often pointed out
jeremy by friends of mine like eric
weinstein and others
uh and his conversation with rabbi david
walpe on the portal podcast you know
some sort of evidence for something
interesting like maybe you'd want to
investigate that just as you might want
to look into you know why is this
particular um you know city in kenya or
in the you know really great at
producing the world record holder
marathon runners and and i think uh i
personally think they're unrelated i i
think that it's it's almost accidental
that so many of these nobel prize
winners are jewish do you ever think
about that i think it's almost
chauvinistic
you know pro for a change about judaism
but uh but yeah but but i think it's
almost accidental because i i know very
few especially in the physical sciences
who are anything but irreligious maybe
anti-religious in the case of folks like
maybe steven weinberg and others so have
you ever thought about this issue of
nobel
secular you know or atheistic jewish
nobel laureates or just eminent
scientists in general yeah i mean
i you could develop different hypotheses
about this it's probably hard to
to prove anything definitively but i
think if i if i had to
guess a clear reason for that
it would be
argued in terms of the historical
details meaning that you know it is
interesting that maybe you have a bunch
of nobel prize winners in the 20th
century but you didn't have a huge
number of jews in the time of faraday or
maxwell um or newton
punching at the same way so what was the
difference right and clearly the
difference was the degree to which
jews in europe were allowed access to
uh a secular society of some sort in
which they could participate
um and and also to the degree to which
they sought that and you know if you go
further back in time
societies were just organized very
differently um and so what i think was
was constant
was that over
more than a thousand years and really
close to 2000 years you had
a
culture
within the jewish world of
trying to inculcate a sense of the value
of
learning a
system's way of thinking about a set of
complex ideas and assumptions and rules
and trying to kind of compute the
consequences of those not always
numerically sometimes really involving
genuine mathematics but often more sort
of in kind of a legal sense but where
there's this this
uh
cultural
love for those kinds of discussions and
examinations of arguments where you're
looking at something and say but what if
i change this rule of the system like
what would be the implications of that
and trying to anticipate weird cases and
and realize ways in which altering your
assumptions you know you can surprise
yourself with what you can compute as
the consequences of that but that was
applied to the study of the torah for
centuries and not really
to the same degree elsewhere
and then you had this huge sea change i
don't know post the napoleonic conquest
like various things that causes all
caused all these shifts and in european
society that started granting jews
access if they wanted to a kind of
society that in principle
wasn't about affiliation with separate
religious groups sort of you know that
were either dominant or
pushed to the margins in certain
respects so you of course had a bunch of
people who still had a lot of kind of
cultural
interest in those kinds of ways of
thinking but suddenly who were kind of
turning away from the traditional
applications of those
and at a time when a lot of ideas were
coming together so
it seems like
you know i don't know nobel prizes is
obviously even a different thing than
kind of participants in a profession
but if you had to kind of make that
argument i would say
often although not always but often you
you get the the biggest prizes in
science for being able to kind of think
outside the box
look at the system as a whole and say
but
should we be assuming these things or or
could we devise a different system that
is consistent with the same empirical
data and you know certainly you see that
you know the grandest example perhaps is
general relativity um and einstein's
insights there right to get gravity from
the geometry of space-time instead of
from a force law you know it's a
completely upside-down way of thinking
about um the same empirical observations
and i think that maybe the plasticity of
thinking that might have originated in a
culture that prized at that kind of
intellectual
um that then suddenly kind of
allowed
a huge portion of its populace to to run
into
a new kind of society with a new set of
you know ideas where and a new ways
ways for them to succeed
you know maybe that you know adds up to
something
um but
it's it's kind of you know you can make
up a theory like that and you can make
up another one
yeah
yeah
yeah i think that there's you know a
danger in kind of using any of these i
personally as i wrote about in my book
uh believe that the nobel prize is sort
of a secular religion
and that the nobel prize is a vote
for people too because they need a
release in some form of religion
even if you're an atheist i had a debate
with friends about this recently you
know
is atheism a religion does it have
trappings of religion well it may it may
not but certainly the nobel prize does
is i convincingly i think if i have to
pat myself on the on my own back it has
holidays it has ritual ceremonies
required regalia it has a priesthood it
has patron saints it has a founding
father a founding mythology rooted in
death and it also has a band of
apostates and
one of the roles that i'm fulfilling i
want to ask you sorry i i
you provoked me on i think the other
thing to say about this is that
it has to do with idol smashing meaning
that there's this tradition going back
to abraham that part of what
ya do it's part of what judaism is about
is
pointing out
the pointlessness of prostration before
a sort of arbitrary construction of
human hands and saying no there's
something more complex and more elevated
and greater that you really should be
sort of lifting your eyes to instead of
worshiping
something you've crafted yourself
and i do think that
gets to your point of your question
about why are there so many
not just jews who have ended up you know
winning this prize but why are so many
of them such a vowed atheist and i think
part of what happened in this strange
way is that
the zeal for idol smashing is kind of
part of
the
[Music]
sort of fire in the belly of of of
jewish culture and that's something that
someone can maintain
even as they maybe become estranged from
religious practice and sort of the whole
religious system of judaism and so you
do have and i i can relate to this
myself personally because this is more
sort of like the household i grew up in
um than the life i'm choosing to live
now but i think you definitely can have
someone who's in this strange way
very much trying to be true to their
jewish self
and and expressing that through their
zeal for smashing idols which is both
good for doing paradigm shifts in
science um and also
is going to make you feel like in order
to be like the best jew you can be you
should be an atheist because all these
things people are talking about that
sound like religion are just kind of
silly forms of idolatry and sometimes
versions of judaism can very even
appropriately appeal i sorry appear to
uh to someone as being too idolatrous to
be acceptable so i think maybe that's
part of it as well
yeah and i i definitely agree with that
and i think there's kind of this eternal
quest in judaism i also think the kind
of adversarial approach in a good way to
learning you know plays a role that has
historically typified you know jews
didn't have opportunities as you say if
we were being pogrommed and run out of
many areas at least in eastern europe
and shuttle life wasn't uh
commensurate with being a gentleman
scientist
of the philosophical tradition of a
faraday or herschel or somebody like
that but but nevertheless i think it is
important to recognize that you know
there is some through line perhaps that
einstein stood on the shoulders of
giants but not only giants of physics as
we will now turn but but also maybe
giants of the you know tradition that he
was heir to
uh even though he you know certainly
didn't practice it and uh you know some
say maybe even would have considered
himself or or you know rejecting it
apostate or some other notion of of god
you know in the spinoza tradition which
is you know typically thought to be
pantheistic or nature or
worshiping of nature or something like
that but i want to turn towards you know
i think the most basic aspect of this
book
uh which is about life and i always you
know pick up these books and um uh
there's a book by you know speaking of
jewish atheists upcoming guest lawrence
krauss or by the time this comes out
maybe it'll already be actually no i
don't think that could violate that will
violate you know certain laws of
continuity and space time but um but
lawrence krauss was coming on he wrote a
book you know called the greatest story
ever told you know kind of mocking of
the bible but then he said why are we
here and there's no reason you know
there's no uh why answer to that
particular why question
and i've always been told that you can't
ask why questions in physics but you can
ask
what questions and one of the through
lines that runs in your book is this
notion and the question or asked in
schrodinger's
1944 monograph
entitled what is life and uh unlike you
know the why questions which you
shouldn't really expect an answer to
that book doesn't really answer the
question uh so i want to ask you what is
life jeremy
try
to
[Music]
maybe wriggle out of this question or
maybe
redefine it beyond all recognition
to some degree
by
saying
we think of this as a hard question but
if we want to we can make it an easy
question because what we can say is that
we really know
how to use the words life and death or
alive and dead and we didn't learn that
from the last several hundred years of
progress in modern science
it's part of the vocabulary of of
regular everyday
speech to just kind of say okay frogs
are alive rocks are not and yes maybe we
can if we look very closely find things
that are more sort of borderline but
that actually takes effort and we have
many examples that are very clear
in how far they are on one side or the
other side of that line
so you could start by just saying look
we know what's alive and what's not and
what we should start trying to ask
ourselves is
how do we make a theory of
from the perspective of physics what the
boundary between those two groups of
things looks like and how you kind of
cross from one to the other and that's
not the same thing as sort of asking for
the definition we we know
um the definition empirically and if we
want to interrogate that through the
lens of physics then we can start saying
what are the distinctive behaviors of
living things when talked about in
physical terms
and that are not necessarily
individually unique
uh to life but when you sort of bundle
them all together they start to sound
like okay yeah that's that sounds like
life so you have to start making a list
you have to divide and conquer living
things make copies of themselves they
self-replicate they
get access to difficult sources of
energy to access in their environment
they
act in ways that seem to instantiate
accurate predictions of their likely
future based on the statistics of their
past and present
and you could go on and start making a
list of various things like that and
each one of them
maybe if you just put it on its own
you'd say okay that's a well-defined
physical phenomenon and it reminds me of
something that life is good at but i
could imagine maybe something that does
that
that isn't definitely not alive so for
example with self-copying a very
primitive form of self-copying is
anything that spreads itself like fire
for example and you don't want to start
saying oh yeah so fire must be alive
because it spreads itself that
just completely you know changes the
definition of life you know beyond
recognition
um
but it does point out okay i could try
to make a model of self-spreading things
or self-copying things and maybe i can
progress on the physics that way i can
make a different model of
you know spontaneous emergence of
predictive behavior in matter that's
subject to a predictable environment and
maybe
some of that prediction will look like
life and some of it will be more
primitive but i can make a theory of
that thing and if i do that over and
over again i maybe start to be able to
sort of
paint the gray spectrum going back from
what we think of as highly developed
life to all these more primitive
emergencies that might have contributed
at the beginning to the assembly of the
first thing that we find very
impressively alive
and so when you read schrodinger's book
or his monograph rather what did you
what's your takeaway do you think there
is
sort of uh importance to that monograph
the way that his contributions and
quantum mechanics were i sort of think
of it as as one of the first
you know hints that some sort of some of
the themes you just mentioned but you
know not a precursor to dna which would
be discovered 13 years later or even
notions of you know the thermodynamic
arguments that you're making in this
book uh sort of more basic in physics
how influential was that monograph to
you
well i think what
schrodinger did very brilliantly
in what is life is really kind of more
pose and try to address from his
perspective the question of how is what
life is how is what life seems to be
doing
understandable to be possible in terms
of physics that we know
i think was sort of meant to be kind of
let's just
deal once and for all
with
notions of vitalism and say
you don't need some
additional physics we don't know about
in order to explain how it could be that
atoms and molecules act this way but if
that's the case then let's be careful
and try to imagine how you would
accomplish some of the things that life
does and he's very famous for example
for hypothesizing that there's some kind
of aperiodic crystal that might be
needed in order to create the heredity
of traits that you see being passed from
a living thing to its offspring
through the molecules that the offspring
is built out of that come from the
living thing and so that's a pretty
impressive thing given that people
didn't yet know what the structure of
dna was and they were still sort of
chasing that down i mean although it
wasn't too much later that watson and
crick and hershey and chase and all
these um
uh famous experiments about dna is the
hereditary material and what it looks
like you know started coming out um
so he's famous for that he's also famous
for thinking about the thermodynamics
and and just making
a starting observation that i don't
think gets you all the way to go which
is just that if you think in terms of
life is a physical process what it must
be doing
it is
a process that's capable of taking parts
of its surroundings and kind of
organizing them into copies of it
themselves and if it's going to do that
it can't do that according to the second
law of thermodynamics without
in the surroundings doing some kind of
counter balancing
increasing of the entropy of the
universe because otherwise you're going
to have a total entropy change on
average that's
not positive
and that would seem to be in violation
of the second law
i think that
while he you know famously made that
observation
um
you don't get a lot of a sense of all
right so
how is this actually
accomplished and i think also
um
the the
the real answer to the questions that
he's posing can mostly be empirical and
they were answered empirically in the
subsequent half a century because a lot
of it was sort of more like life is
doing this so how how could it be doing
that and he had a lot of brilliant
insights into you know what might be
possible for someone who didn't have a
lot of experimental data to work with
and then you start being able to just do
experiments and a lot of your methods
get more precise and accurate and you
start people say oh okay so this is how
muscles work
there are proteins and they have
chemical fuels like atp and they change
their shapes when they burn the chemical
fuel and they're all strung together in
such a way that when they change their
shapes there's this kind of concerted
action that can produce a force
and so
it's explaining life and its beauty and
its functioning
at the macroscopic level by tracing it
back to all of these molecular physical
events and that's really cool but it's
very much empirical and it's very much
let's look and see and let's try to
understand and it's a different question
than why would matter get this way in
the first place right like if you
started with matter that was not in any
particularly interesting shape
none of that discussion really touches
the question of why it would get knocked
into that shape and and whether it would
have to be put into that shape by
something that sort of was already
equally specially shaped or whether the
special shapes can kind of get knocked
together by
somehow more primitive patterns in the
environment so i think that
the emergence question is a separate one
from the
how is this possible question and it
really took a half century of
elaborating the answer to the question
how this is possible to start
really laying the ground for thinking
more precisely about the emergence
question so i think he was really
seminal clearly and in another sense
the experimental
findings that came afterwards were
equally if not more important to
launching any serious discussion about
the emergence question i would say
so this question comes from a friend lee
cronin the regis professor regis
professor at
university of glasgow uh he'll be a
guest on the podcast uh in uh in the
summer
and he's asking you know he's very
provocative and a little bit uh quirky
but he does say and he wants me to
communicate to you
um your thoughts on why is
thermodynamics particularly relevant to
this discussion in other words his his
question is why not have a gravitational
uh description of life you know how why
is it thermodynamics is privileged in
some sense
i i have to kind of i mean it seems like
a total evasion to answer this way
especially given the subtitle of the
book which means thermodynamics but in a
sense it's not about thermodynamics so
much as a statement about dynamical
systems with many pieces like you could
talk about it in more general terms
um
but i think that the reason that
thermodynamics is
important is because
it grounds you in
a theoretical frame where you can speak
with rigor about
the probabilities of different events
happening in a system and their
relationship
to
a surrounding environment and exchanges
of different kinds that can happen with
that environment that's what
thermodynamics has always been from the
beginning when it was first just kind of
a theory of how heat engines can work
and whether they can be more or less
efficient
and it has remained that way when you
start to think of it more in microscopic
terms um and i think that doesn't mean
there aren't ways of thinking in these
terms where maybe you could try to
abstract away and say i don't want to
talk about energy i don't want to talk
about temperature because really what
this is about ultimately is you're going
to make a model of a system and say
what is the probability distribution
for different things that could happen
in the future of the system
given the dynamical rules that i've made
for how it kind of
hops from one state to another like you
know so i have these local changes that
i can make these uh more sort of
incremental modifications to the
structure of the system and i have some
rules mapped out for how that's allowed
to happen so how do i predict the long
time behavior um and what what
thermodynamics is is very
good for is grounding you in things like
conservation of energy right so energy
from movies and stuff we tend to think
of now as like you know glowing stuff
that flies from one place to another and
blow stuff up um and indeed maybe it
could be in a certain case like that but
if we really want to go back to the
beginning of the idea of energy what is
it energy is either just motion or the
potential to produce motion right it
gets more complicated with relativity
and you know mass energy and stuff like
that but let's just you know bracket
that we don't need it and i don't think
it fundamentally changes the point being
made here so we just think in terms of
newtonian mechanics
you have stuff that's moving and it has
kinetic energy and you have potential
energy which is forces that could cause
things to start moving
um and
the conservation of energy it just
allows you to think about exchanges of
the stuff that either produces motion or
is motion from one place to another and
what living things always are are open
systems that are exchanging matter and
energy with their surroundings
and i think the key thing
is this this feedback loop that you can
point to um that allows you to start
thinking in evolutionary terms in a way
that
helps you to realize there's kind of the
potential for
an evolutionary adaptation
that could be more general than what we
usually think of as the darwinian model
so the darwinian model is things make
copies of themselves the properties they
pass on to the copies are going to
impact those copies ability to copy
themselves and so you end up with this
kind of tendency to have persistence and
amplification of properties that help
things to copy themselves if you don't
have self-copying things you can't make
that argument but if you have matter of
any kind especially if you have
collections of lots of particles that
are capable of lots of different kinds
of shapes
the generalization of that argument and
it really rigorously is a generalization
is the idea that you don't have copies
and genes
but what you have is matter that's in a
shape and it could be in other shapes
it's building blocks that are assembled
one way and they could be taken apart
and reassembled in a different way
and the key point with energy is just
this energy is both the reason you're
going to change your shape
and it also
gets into or out of the system in a way
that's affected by your shape so if it's
the case on the one hand that the shape
that your matter is currently in is
going to have an impact on how energy
can get in
and what kinds of motions it's capable
of producing and at the same time that
access to energy is that the reason
you're going to be changing your
configuration and trying out a new shape
that is the feedback loop that closes
where now you're going to do
a biased exploration of the space of
possible configurations that has to do
with access to the flow of energy in and
out of the system
and that's the that's what i've tried to
argue for in in various published works
and including this book but you know
also in research papers that we've
called dissipative adaptation the idea
is basically that there's a selection
principle you can argue for or maybe a
family of selection principles depending
on the type of system
where
the way the matter in the system acts as
a receiver for flow of energy in and out
you know given the state of the
environment or the patterns in the
environment
that is the property you should be
looking at that's going to be kind of
selected or
or chosen perhaps to be in a very rare
and special kind of configuration over
time
as a result of the fact that you're in
this environment and getting kicked
around by the patterns in it and the
eventual impact of that energy flow is
maybe going to care a lot about what
shape you're in and what kind of access
to that energy that shape and what kind
of access to that energy that shape
grants
and so based on that
question or that explanation rather
would we expect to find
you know perhaps new
experimental predictions or observations
that could be observed as a result of
experiments should the hypothesis should
dissipate of adaptation be correct in
other words he's wondering how do you
substantiate that it is
capable of the novel predictive element
and i was thinking as i was reading the
book you know the shape of dna and rna
are different and there should be some
you know way of of of using just those
simple but but also highly interrelated
molecules um maybe in tests or some way
to to justify the flow of energy and
dissipation of it uh are there new
experimental probes uh am i totally way
off base or is that is it too soon to
tell as they say
so
i don't entirely think it's too soon
what i would say is that whenever we're
talking about actually living from the
standpoint of physics as being these
incredibly
complex many component systems that are
in an exquisitely special initial
condition that we don't know right
because they all are the progeny of
things that have been copying themselves
for eons and have been under this
darwinian regime of selection and given
that that's the case then uh there's a
lot that you could explain about what's
very special about how they seem to be
arranged
using that argument
so in some ways i think in order to
see the potential for this other kind of
selective pressure
it might be healthier to start by
looking in places that are definitely
not alive
although i can return to the question of
what you maybe look could look for in
living things in a second uh but we had
a paper come out um in science magazine
at the start of 2021 for example where
we were looking at this
in swarm robotics just trying to do this
as a simple
a paradigm for experimentation in active
matter where what you say is alright i
have a bunch of
relatively simple particles that can
sort of flap their arms according to
patterns that i devise and then i let
them bang into each other and sort of
knock into each other cause each other
to move and they end up getting in these
different kinds of regular dances
together
that are very spontaneous and emerging
in the sense that if you change the
pattern then the dance they discover is
different but there are these kind of
attractor states that are very stable
even though the space of all the
possible arrangements is quite vast and
diverse
and so you can start to look at what's
the relationship between the pattern
that i chose and the selected state the
selected dynamical state that the system
ends up getting into and
in in short there is a predictive
principle there that does have to do
with this question um of how
the driving forces that are
you know in a patterned way hitting the
system are devolving that energy and
whether it's going to be randomizing um
given the state you're in or whether it
somehow can produce orderly motion um
and so
i think that in one sense the thing i
advocate for is let's push this into an
experimental setting where we're just
trying to do proofs of principle on a
tabletop that don't necessarily have to
do with the emergence of life
immediately but more have to do with
a simpler emergence phenomena we can
study carefully where it's about saying
can i develop very good experimental and
predictive control over a system where i
show it patterns in terms of how i poke
it and then i have predictive power over
the emergence structure and its ability
to respond to those patterns
that the system is going to discover by
being knocked around in that way and i
think if we did that for a while and got
really good at it it would kind of be
like how we now understand where
crystals come from right like
we don't think anymore well how can
there be crystals in the world they're
so organized and
there's no explanation for this special
organization of matter other than that
aliens came and put them in rows but you
know we have we know they're attractive
forces between molecules and actually if
the temperature is low enough then that
can overwhelm the tendency to randomize
and you can end up getting a very
orderly state so you can get very
specially organized things from
equilibrium crystallization
and we're not bothered anymore when we
see crystals that we see lying on the
ground life is obviously much more
complicated than that it's not at
equilibrium the things that it's doing
are more impressive and cooler in some
ways um
and more elaborate and variegated
but i think there's a lot of things
about life-like behavior also where you
could say oh if we if we develop enough
of an understanding on a tabletop so to
speak of how to make those kinds of
phenomena and and do them in
sophisticated ways maybe we'll start to
say okay so some of what impresses us
about what life is doing far from
equilibrium
actually
is realizable and emergable in an
experimental setting so that is i i'd
bracket around that the best tests in
the short term for the theoretical ideas
may not be about making life they may be
more like
getting better experimental control over
more primitive life-like forms of
self-organization when you're showing
patterns to systems that have lots of
states that they could explore
that being said
yeah no i i i enjoy that uh it seems
like in soft condensed matter as i
understand it you could actually test
you know from the most distinctive
feature of dissipative adaptation is
that you know there's
more efficient and less efficient you
know versions of things in shape space
and that you could almost envision a
non-biological evolutionary
pathway i'm wondering if i'm getting
that right if you could design
experiments on non-living you know my
colleagues use little tiny magnetic
motors to simulate flagella i wonder are
there ways to
you know utilize the shape space
landscape for lack of a better word to
evolve things not biologically but
chemically and see what are their energy
properties after
thousands of generations whatever that
means of evolution
yeah so i think that is
that whenever you're talking about
selection and adaptation what this is
ultimately about is the idea that there
are many random arrangements of
constituent parts
and there's a
very tiny subset of those arrangements
that have some special property
and that property has a measurable
and clear definition in terms of
the relationship between
that particular set of arrangements of
the system and some kind of pattern in
the environment and if you can set up a
situation where
you can predict and control
what arrangements of the matter are
going to be selected given the pattern
that you're showing whether it's like
your shining light of this frequency or
you're pulsing it in this way or you're
also changing the temperature in this
way all the different ways you can kind
of keep things away from equilibrium
that might have some kind of pattern or
predictable but maybe also kind of
complex structure to them
then
you get the opportunity for the system
to give back to you something that's
very recognizably sort of bearing the
stamp of the bar code of what you were
showing to it in the pattern of the
environment so
you're not
you're not going through generations
because there isn't
um the darwinian sort of feedback
process of self-copying but what you're
going through is a series of shapes the
system was in
and
it's about
you know you don't have parents and
grandparents what you have is antecedent
shapes shapes you used to be in
who had a particular ability to get
pushed on by the environment in a
certain way and because they have that
ability that allowed them to change
their shape in a certain way and that
irreversible configurational change ends
up getting written on the shape of the
system and kind of accumulates in such a
way that it eventually you start to say
wow i'm in a very rare and special shape
i wouldn't expect to see
and i can tell that because i so to
speak have a way that i've barcoded the
environment in a very particular way
that it is complexly patterned and then
what i see is that the system has
emerged an ability to compute something
about it or respond to it um in a
recognizable way so we have a paper or
two
about
simulations of many body systems that do
that where it's it's kind of like a a
simulation of a lattice of atoms that
can flip their magnetic moments up and
down so like what's called a spin glass
and you just sort of knock on the atoms
with a bar-coded pattern where some of
them are getting flipped up and some of
them are getting flipped down and then
over time the system kind of learns to
not be rearranged by the patterns of
barcodes that you're showing it and then
if you start showing new barcodes then
it goes crazy and jumps around and the
work absorption goes ways up you know
sorry it goes way up and so in a sense
you've without programming anything
you've evolved
in the system an ability to
predict
the future and kind of notice when that
prediction turns out to be inaccurate
um and and so it sort of becomes this
this weird kind of backdoor into machine
learning where
unprogrammed disordered matter if
there's just a lot of particles and you
show it patterns is kind of optimizing
input output relationships in ways that
kind of look like the result of a
process of machine learning
i wondered as i read through the book
you make a convincing case that
self-replicating molecules are somehow
privileged or best at you know creating
organized complex systems but um
simultaneously doing so
efficiently dumping heat or entropy
into their surroundings and it reminded
me of this book that i had the author
caleb scharf on recently called the
ascent of information with the play on
the words of of darwin's ascent of man
and uh he talks about how information
compression
is uh getting less and less efficient in
other words uh he says he talks about
you know taking you know basically stone
tablets and hieroglyphics and then
movable type
and then uh and then you know eventually
getting into information processing by
way of microchips and he says
uh the smaller chips get the more
inefficient it becomes to push electrons
through all that increasingly narrow
conductive material and the more heat
gets generated and he talks about by the
year 2040
the humanities computation will suck up
uh 10 to the 20th joules of energy per
year which is about 100 trillion times
the amount of energy that is being used
for information transmission and storage
etc today so 100 million in uh less than
20 years is quite startling well beyond
moore's law
but it made me think
um you know is it a correlation or is it
a causation in other words are things
more fascined
and
and
and and more successful in terms of
selection
because they're more efficient at
dumping heat or entropy to their
surroundings or is it the other way
around you know the ones that we is
correlated rather than a causative
feature of the uh conversion of you know
of of of heat of energy into waste heat
or entropy what is it is there a
darwinian principle that could be
applied to
entropy flow in uh you know microsystems
so i think we have to be careful about
this
for a few reasons one is that
in what we have called dissipative
adaptation it really it breaks into
cases that can have opposite
long-term impacts on
energy flow through the system so
the hallmark in either case would be you
have some pattern in the environment
and the system is
becoming finely tuned to that pattern
and how it processes it so that you have
a there's a recognizable exceptionality
in the organization the system as far as
how it responds to the pattern sometimes
that could be that it's going to get
better at absorbing energy from the
pattern and so for example when you have
bugs
that are meaning like bacteria or
something that copy themselves and make
more of themselves and then they're
going to eat more rapidly through the
food that's around them that's like a
positive feedback loop where
they're going to catalyze
more dissipation more rapidly over time
but you also could have negative
feedback loops that
go to extinction of of energy absorption
and they would also be considered
instances of fine-tuning to an
environmental pattern so i think that
the fundamental general thermodynamic
argument doesn't guarantee that
something should go up or down
it really starts to be about the details
of the particular working material and
the particular patterns that you're
talking about whether you're going to
see dominance of positive feedback
effects or negative feedback effects i
think both of these actually lead to
different kinds of lifelike behavior
self-replication is obviously a famous
one another less famous one which maybe
is closer to the title of the book is
about how life gets into these shapes
that are absorbing energy from the
environment and despite the fact that
they are they're not being randomly
rearranged right like i can't just stop
eating sandwiches for lunch and start
getting an equivalent dose of gamma rays
and jewels and expect to be healthy
afterwards right and the reason for that
is because
random introductions or i should say uh
unsuitable introductions of energy into
the system will produce randomizing
effects there'll be a bowl in a china
shop and sort of rip things to
smithereens
so the emergence of a structure that's
stable despite all the energy flowing
through it actually can happen as the
system adapts to reduce the work
absorption and make sure that the work
it is absorbing is producing kind of
closed loops that bring you back to the
same state instead of kind of carrying
you in new directions and that's one of
the things that life is also good at
so life is this bundle of a lot of
different things going on at once and i
think that it becomes
very hard to just sit in the sort of
armchair of thermodynamics and say i
know exactly what should happen
you know over there because
energy goes in and entropy has to be
produced what i always try to point out
is that you know both
los angeles and north korea are equally
possible according to the laws of
thermodynamics right like you know that
picture from space in terms of you know
how much you can see uh lights on at
night
it's all permitted like thermodynamics
in one sense produces weak constraints
on what's possible that are very hard if
you try to run against them but it's a
very capacious playground for different
kinds of dynamics
and i think similarly when talking about
microchips
it's true that you can measure wattage
in a lot of systems and it's true
sometimes that there are feedback
processes that are leading to growth or
decay of wattage or changes in
efficiency
but operating near the limits of
thermodynamic efficiency sorry the
thermodynamic limits of efficiency
is not necessarily
always what we're doing with our
engineering and so it may not end up
setting a bound that is necessarily
relevant to where technology is going at
a given moment
in your recent conversation with paul
davies on unbelievable with justin
bierly you talked a little bit about
intel uh information and information
information
management perhaps but you know of
course the most
the most amount of information that you
could transmit you know typically would
be something of order of a black body
radiation in other words highly entropic
very low distinguishing features you
know that can conveying the most
amount of possible randomized complex
information so what do you mean by
saying that you know these these things
are very good at information management
and even prediction
how does dna make a prediction or how
does it have any predictive ability
whatsoever
you're
going to look at that question through
the lens of biology then what i would
say is the genes of a living thing
that's well adapted to its environment
imply a prediction about what that
living thing expects to be there in its
environment for example if you have
genes that produce proteins that help
you do oxidative metabolism why would
you do that if there were no oxygen
right so but there's implicitly an
expectation that there is going to be
oxygen around for you to make use of and
that's why all of this machinery is in
place to produce things that can exploit
that oxygen for this sort of uh
purpose of survival and reproduction of
the living thing so i think the
teleology is kind of easier to think
through if you are talking about dna in
a biological context if you're talking
about
matter that isn't alive
then i think it has more you have to you
have to be a little to step back a
little bit further and just talk about
it in terms of
behaving in a way that could be used as
a predictor of a complex signal so in
other words
um let's say
in this example that i was describing
before i'm showing a system a bunch of
random barcodes and let's say the
barcodes have you know
i don't know
100 bits in them so 2 to the 100 is a
big number right
there's lots of different random
barcodes you can make let's say i'm only
going to show you a thousand barcodes
but they were randomly selected so if i
start showing you barcodes that will
seem to you to be kind of random
because you won't notice any pattern
initially and yet a thousand out of two
to the 100 is a very very tiny fraction
so in fact there's a lot of correlations
there there's a lot of pattern there to
learn
if the right kind of learner gets to
pick up on the lower dimensionality or
the sort of
rarity or special selectedness of the
particular subset of these barcodes that
it's being shown
so
dumb matter behaving according to very
sensibly thermodynamically defined
dynamical rules can be knocked down with
barcodes like that and get into a state
where it will just keep on chugging
along in terms of
the flow of energy through the system if
you keep showing it barcodes taken from
the same deck of cards so to speak but
if you start showing it new ones it'll
suddenly spike up in terms of the energy
that it's absorbing and and you could
use that as a novelty detector right you
could say in a sense i've built
a machine so to speak that could detect
novelty in a complex signal that i'm
showing it
so
it has learned something that implies a
prediction but only if you sort of look
for it in the right way um and and
that's a less uh obviously lifelike way
to act but i think it's kind of
at the beginning of things that we think
of life as being good at because
everything
at the beginning when you're trying to
pull life together it's going to be
about to what degree is this piece of
matter this hunk of of the world in a
state that seems
highly specialized in its input output
relationship with patterns in its
surroundings and if i start to have a
lot of that lying around as kind of a
rough cut
then maybe i get to pull that together
into
the first living thing in a way that
makes it easier to assemble that than if
i had some naive null model of oh well
everything i'm assembling is just
totally inert naive and doesn't know
anything about the patterns around us
very good um now i'm going to take some
questions from my audience that
submitted them
on youtube reminder you can submit
questions to me on youtube dr brian
keating if you're listening to this i do
make the videos different
than the audio that you're hearing if
you're listening to this in audio only
form i try to add
a lot of interesting background material
and links to research etc that's hard to
include
in a couple of thousand character
uh information storage unit that they
give us in podcast
uh so what i want to ask first is from a
reader uh or what viewer whose last name
is stankevich
i think first initial is d uh first one
is he asked or she asked could you talk
about trends in biophysics research and
what's the most exciting and next big
thing in that area according to your
opinion
so
i'm gonna
inject my own bias into this because i'm
sure there's a lot of different kinds of
exciting biophysics research and i
shouldn't claim to know the most
interesting one
by all standards but i think a very
exciting arena to explore is what's
called the cytosol so in a living cell
you have a whole lot of different kinds
of proteins that have been produced
from the genetic code in the dna and
they're sort of the like workhorse micro
machines or nano machines of the cell so
the cell is this very dense bag of all
these different proteins that are each
kind of these knobbly little
macromolecules that have different
shapes but the important thing is they
can change their shape and how they
change their shape depends on what kind
of chemical fuels they get to chew on
also how mobile they are can be impacted
by what chemical fuels they're chewing
on how they change their shape can also
be affected by how they bind to each
other
and also they can
cause
uh changes in shape of other ones that
are triggered by the chemical fuels that
they're chewing on so when you sort of
close all those different feedback loops
what you have is this immensely high
dimensional many body system
that
has all these different states of
assembly that it could be in right all
these different places the proteins
could be the shapes the proteins could
be in while they're stuck to each other
and all of that is modulated by the flow
of energy through the system
via all these different kinds of small
molecule chemical fuels that are
catalyzed in in different kinds of
enzymatic reactions
so if you if you add that all together
according to what i was just describing
in the physics of dissipative adaptation
this should be a very ripe playground
for
the emergence of selected fine-tuned
many-body states
that
are responsive to the patterns of
availability of different kinds of
energy sources that have to do with the
current condition or state of the cell
so what that means is there's a lot in
principle that just a totally naive cell
that has never sort of seen the patterns
of its current environment
could end up computing in a
self-organized way
uh if you could figure out what the
optimization principle is like if
i know enough about
what the inputs
are are going to look like to the
network of interacting components i just
described then maybe i could say there's
a kind of machine learning that the
interior of the cell is doing every time
patterns around it change and if that's
true then some of what the cell might be
doing that looks very specialized to us
and looks very smart and adapted and
responsive to what the environment is
doing might not actually come
from what we often assume which is some
kind of programmed response in the dna
that tells the cell all these things
about its evolutionary history and how
to respond it may be that there's a lot
more
adaptation that could be going on on
faster time scales and you start to see
evidence of this in various uh kinds of
of research
programs in cell biology that are going
on at present
people like you and zachi pilpel
at the weitzman institute here in israel
for example um and many others as well
so i think it's it's a very
hot topic um in cell biology right now
is to what degree can you kind of
self-organize what the cell needs from
mechanisms that might actually
be
more responsive
and less
ancient
than what you have to kind of learn over
the eons of selection that applies to
the dna
very good okay next question comes
from john hardy as a viewer he wants me
to ask you about combinatorial explosion
of amino acid arrangements
and the implausibility according to him
of random biogenesis and evolution
what do you care to say about that
jeremy yeah so i think there's kind of a
general comment to make and then there's
um
maybe i'll start with just a very brief
empirical comment that i think that
different kinds of studies about protein
function and the degree to which you can
get things that look functional from
randomly assembled proteins have pointed
in different directions over the years
on the one hand if you string together a
bunch of amino acids you you can see
evidence that a lot of it tends to
aggregate and it doesn't really fold
into
you know very effective enzymes on the
other hand there's some
very interesting work from the lab of
michael hecht at princeton and the
chemistry department where you are kind
of making a mostly randomly assembled
protein that has it turns out a lot of
weak and promiscuous enzymatic
activities and if you take cells that
are lacking in enzymatic activities that
can't survive on on nutrient poor media
and kind of transform
random hunks of protein into them you
actually can rescue them in some cases
so
there are in synthetic biology some
kinds of evidence that point towards oh
well if you wanted to sort of i mean
this is crazy in a sense it's like
taking a living thing saying i'll take
out your liver i'll pull in a pine cone
and maybe that will help you know so
that sounds like it shouldn't work and i
think at our macroscopic level it
obviously doesn't but cells are maybe
you know primitive or maybe that's the
wrong word but they're down
in the molecular scale noisy dumps
enough in terms of all the different
things happening that maybe just kind of
blasting the system with some new
different enzymatic activities can help
it get back on its feet
so there's different kinds of evidence
that maybe point different ways there
but i think that
the other thing that it's just like a
good general principle for these kinds
of discussions
is that whenever we're trying to argue
that something about what life is doing
um or the universe for that matter other
kinds of fine-tuning arguments people
make
whenever we're trying to make that
argument we have to be very clear
with ourselves
about how well we understand the process
that produces the probability
distribution of possible outcomes and
that's kind of most obviously the case
when you talk about like what's the
probability of producing the universe
with certain laws of physics right
people like to talk about that but
i've never seen a universe producing
process happen and i don't know kind of
what the random number generators
contributing to that look like
but if you look at it in biology i think
it's even more kind of it's easy to say
we can be humble just in that it's so
complex that the fact that we can't
imagine how things could have gotten the
way they are might just be a limitation
of our imagination so at the moment we
compute some probability value and it
seems very small but it might be again
because the assumptions that went into
that are the wrong ones and once we
realize how certain things are possible
and make different assumptions
probabilities can suddenly be way
different orders of magnitude different
um so any kinds of id sorts of arguments
that end up being based around well i
thought really hard and i can't see how
you get a protein motor without you know
flipping heads a trillion times in a row
on a coin
that's a model of the probability for
the outcome that has been constructed
according to certain assumptions
but maybe those assumptions have to be
questioned and as long as you can play
the game it's very hard to disprove
[Music]
the possibility of something emerging
without
um
some kind of tampering uh because what
we're always kind of saying is like i
give up i can't think of how my p-value
is at this level i'm done and i'd like
i'd rather you know point to the the
alternative hypothesis but
you can also keep thinking and maybe you
come up with a different set of
assumptions that
change the p-value to a more plausible
one
uh this one comes from a visionary
friend of mine delon levy who asks
how is it possible or why does
maximizing the dissipation of heat
cause structure and order to appear
i guess there
one answer to that question is
whenever you have
many pieces of something
um
that could be assembled in many
different ways and you take a property
of their relationship to the environment
maybe any property or at least a broad
variety of properties and you say i'm
going to maximize it or i'm going to
minimize it either way
you are likely to get something that
looks orderly to you because what we
mean by order and function in a sense is
that this is a rare arrangement of the
building blocks that is exceptional
compared with a randomly chosen
arrangement of its constituent parts and
so when we extremize when we try to make
something maximally good at something or
minimally good at something we end up
finding very exceptional and rare
arrangements and that's almost the
definition of function and order
it is not the case that
matter is always trying to maximize
the energy dissipation or the entropy
production sometimes matter ends up in
dynamical states that make it try to do
that it also sometimes is trying to
minimize it
but in both cases you can get things
that look orderly as a result so that's
the way i i would put that
and then the last question from my
listeners and my viewers or other on
youtube a reminder you know when i put
out a call for questions uh people are
delightfully encouraged to respond on
the community page or my post there and
this comes from scarlett morgan
and she writes orthodox rabbi england is
the son of a jewish mother descended
from holocaust survivors and a lutheran
father who he meaning you
did not formally study judaism until his
attendance in oxford his spiritual story
must be as intriguingly powerful as his
amazing intellect
please ask this generation's charles
darwin and future nobel laureate well
maybe not after appearing on my show but
uh future nobel laureate to elaborate
further dr keating and they're probably
asking because they know i have the
distinction of uh being born to two
biological jewish parents but also
having been an altar boy in the catholic
church for several years but i want to
ask you jeremy so you're the second or
maybe maybe you know
you're the second guest slash host uh
to have an unusual approach to orthodox
judaism or practicing judaism can you
talk a little bit about your uh
religious uh journey or world line as we
say in general relativity that brought
you to become a rabbi and uh tell us a
little bit about that if you would sure
yeah absolutely in that
you know when i grew up i had
very
warm feeling towards jewish identity as
something that was part of my family
history and i think that i actually got
a lot of
kind of cultural introduction to ideas i
didn't really realize at the time were
ones that i could have also learned from
a more systematic exposure to judaism
and i just thought they were like oh
that's my personal philosophy or
something and then um in in young
adulthood after already studying a lot
of science
um and and really kind of growing up as
a scientist
i i started reading um
in various ways you know at a time in
life where i was asking a lot of
questions i was i visited israel for the
first time was falling in love uh with
the place and and
with a sense of connection to the jewish
people and lots of things were happening
at once i was reading um rabbi jordan uh
rabbi jonathan sachs um a blessed memory
he passed away unfortunately in the last
year
but he was a a really
influential early
contribution to my thinking because he
wrote very clearly about
in the language of western philosophy
what is distinct about the position
taken by
judaism or the the prophets of the
hebrew bible and it really spoke to me
so it all kind of started from there
and then i think for a long time early
on what i just said was i want to do
this because of a feeling of personal
connection and i i understood it as a
choice in how to act and how to talk
and i didn't really get bothered much
about well what do i believe about the
world and what it is and how it works
and whether there is a god like i used
to love to say
i'm not sure whether god exists but i
know what he expects of me you know and
and and
i would focus on
committing to doing what the the torah
proposes one should try to do
because i was kind of embracing my
heritage and that felt like enough to me
for a long time i think that as time
went on i got more interested in kind of
the
maybe you could call them more
philosophical or theological aspects
of the question and as i studied the
torah and the hebrew bible more and as
it became clearly a more essential
you know set of choices i was making how
to live my life and start a family and
everything and
i would say now that um
i i
it's it's clearer to me
over time
that
uh
the torah knows what it is to reason
about the world scientifically
um and to try to predict the natural
world using that way of reasoning
and both
sees great
potential and positive application in
that
but also
limitations in terms of what you can
talk about in the world if you're going
to
limit yourself to that methodology right
because science is a process a social
process that is a compact based around
certain kinds of targets you're aiming
for you're trying to go for
reproducibility you're trying to go for
objectivity things that seem the same to
everyone um but a lot of our experience
actually is subjective and then the
question is whether you should
discard all of that which cannot be made
you know at least approximately
objective or whether
you just should have different languages
or methodologies for how you interpret
the parts of your experience that are
subjective and you sort of make that
part of how you understand what the
world is and what your place is in it
and i think what's funny actually i'll
just like close off
i i maybe didn't give enough a sense of
my history and there's more i could say
but i'll close up i'm making this point
that we were talking about probabilities
with amino acids before
i think
the funny thing to me the ironic thing
is that when it comes to arguments about
observations made within the scientific
context that maybe skew in the direction
of a kind of intelligent design argument
i tend to reject those because
i frequently feel like
science can always keep trying
to
uncover a better set of assumptions that
will end up making the p-values like the
probability of what we observe
seemed to cohere more with what the
models were making of the world
uh tell us we should be observing and so
at any point you can just say i give up
i don't want to keep doing science and
right now the p-value on what i'm seeing
seems really low but you could always
keep chipping away at it and working at
it right but i think the irony is that
when it comes to talking about personal
experience
i think that the torah really teaches
like the hebrew bible
is is very interested in how to teach us
to look for the hand of the world's
creator in the events of our lives and
the events of
the world and in particular in the
hebrew bible in the national history of
the jewish people um
by by by in a sense um looking for
that same kind of improbability because
when you're looking in the subjective
space it's it becomes more legitimate to
just say this seems like a message to me
like the difference between a
coincidence and a message is just many
orders of magnitude in the likelihood of
that right like if if you found
a smudge of dust on your desk that kind
of looked like your initials you'd be
like
maybe that happened by accident if you
found a letter on your desk that said
you know dear brian i would like to meet
with you at this address on this date
you wouldn't just say well maybe a
thermal fluctuation assembled that on my
desk it is a message it has it has
meaning right and the difference is just
you know the the relative likelihood of
that happening you know by accident
so what's interesting is is that you you
always kind of have the opportunity if
you want to look at the events of your
life and your experience and and notice
the things about them that seem too
improbable uh to to be anything other
than sort of a message from the creator
of the world but that's kind of a
dangerous way to you know go out into
the world if you're not grounded in some
way and i think that in a very subtle
way what the torah tries to do
is on the one hand
give you the opportunity
to relate to experience uh in in in a
fashion that has to do with the kind of
the personal dialogue
that you can have if you if you see the
events of the world as as part of a
message and at the same time also to
ground you and say
but don't just do what the message says
you know mostly what you should be doing
is reading this message that's here in
this book and it has very specific
grounded expectations you know love your
neighbor as yourself don't murder people
etc um and and then every so often lift
your head up and try to sort of
uh sense
the
personal relationship that's possible if
you've grounded cell grounded yourself
where your creator wants you to ground
yourself uh and and i i think it's not
an easy sort of path to walk but
these days i would say that's more sort
of where i'm planting my feet
yeah i mean i always say that you know
in the in the torah there are you know
35 verses
out of a possible 35 000 or so verses in
the totality of the chumash of the five
books of moses the old testament the
bible if you call it that
and you know that's 0.1 percent and if
you pick up a book you know let's say i
pick up a book on you know it says you
know introduction to cosmological
physics and then you know the first uh
the first page is about you know
cosmological physics but then the rest
of it you know all 999 other pages are
about uh you know the the search for for
life on mars or something it's not
actually accurately titled and you know
so i thought it would be fun to pivot to
you know kind of the classic questions
that i get
and maybe rebut some of them uh with
your impromature attached to them i
often hear things from my atheist
friends of which i have many and then
gladly host all the time
but you know they say things like well i
don't want to teach lies you know i
religion has practical benefits and i
even said this to freeman dyson the late
great feman dyson who's my first guest
on the into the impossible podcast
of blessed memory and he used to say i'm
an agnostic
and i used to say well looking at you as
an intelligent alien looking at you how
could he or she or it or they or
whatever distinguish you from richard
dawkins i mean you both don't go to the
same church so you know is it about
practice is it about practicality in
other words if you could get all the
benefits of the religion that we just
discussed you know from some secular
pursuit you know would you say that
they're equal or or or not and you know
from my perspective there is there's too
much wisdom in the torah to ignore but
as you point out in in this book
if it's only a metaphor or if it is a
metaphor then you know it's not exactly
clear are you bound to honor you know
and and obey a metaphorical god so i
want to ask you those big pictures you
know how can a scientist you know
physicist uh you know road scholar how
can you take the torah seriously
do you process it in context of of
mainly you know kind of the ten
commandments and and this rules for
living or is it a vivid presence in your
life is the existence of god
tangible almost visceral to you or is it
so abstract that we can't even approach
it
i would say that the
approach that i have i shouldn't say
settled on because it's always you know
a process that keeps on going on and you
keep learning and changing and
developing etc but i think where i am
right now is
on the one hand
it is a very tangible and real and
visceral sense in which i would say
i assert that i i feel in my bones the
world the universe everything that is
was created by the god described in the
hebrew bible
and
that
my experience of the world
and what i study in the torah etc
combined to be a convincing testament to
that
at the same time
i also don't think
that
what i've just said in my own head makes
sense
if i were to read
the torah
in
the way that it sometimes is assumed you
must read it if you believe what i just
said meaning that
if you think really there is really
one god who made the world then you must
also open up the book of genesis and
start reading it and assume that the
genre of literature that you're reading
uh
is in a sense
a
uh
you know write-up of a baseball game
that is is describing
in dry terms a set of occurrences
as observed by someone who was there and
that that's the the sort of the goal of
the text
the torah is not a phone book so there
are clearly uses to which you can put
sources of information or or
media of communication
um that are going to be unsuccessful and
they're ones that are going to be
successful
so i think there's a language or many
languages in a sense that the torah is
trying to speak uh and it has a
particular mission and goal
it's entirely focused on the reader
being what it sees as an oven hashem
meaning a servant of god
and it's trying to enable the mission
of serving god
and in order to do that it's going to
talk about what the world is in a
certain way it's going to use a certain
taxonomy and vocabulary it starts with
the idea that you know
and god said let there be light and
there was light which i i would say at
least part of the point of
is that the light by which you see the
world comes from the way you talk about
it so you can talk about the same world
in different ways
and
if you want to be successful
in the mission of serving god then you
don't start with here's dna here's
electrons etc you start with light and
dark and land and sea and men and women
and fish and birds and you know this is
the fundamental
vocabulary from which you're gonna you
know build everything else
so
the the way that the torah chooses to
characterize and talk about what the
world is there's a lot we should be
trying to learn from that if we accept
upon ourselves the mission to which the
text is calling its reader
but
you can believe that the text was given
to you by the hand of an all-powerful
and all-knowing creator of the universe
and still it can be the case that he
chose to write in a very elliptical way
or in a way that is
you know
carries things sideways a lot of the
time i mean
in one sense you could say
um
if he's going to
show you
how he wants to talk to you and and the
first thing he does is say well plants
came on day three and the sun came on
day four
you don't have to be you know richard
feynman to notice that that's a little
weird because plants need the sun don't
they
and and so
it's not a typo right it's it's it's
trying to be obvious it's trying to say
look
your creator is talking to you and
here's how he wants to talk to you if
he's going to talk to you about how he
acts in the world it's going to be weird
it's going to be hard to make sense of
given your experience of how the world
seems to work
um and and so i think i i try to always
avoid talking about what's metaphorical
and what's literal
because i think that distinction is
deliberately
blurred
beyond recognition
in how the hebrew bible tries to
characterize the human experience for
very good reasons
but i do think
it is possible to relate to the text as
having many meanings that require
interpretation and extraction and that
that's the real treasure to be found
there and at the same time you can
relate to your experience of life and
the world um and also your your you know
the the authority with which you invest
the text um
with the confidence of someone who says
i really am seeing the whole world as as
being the expression of the will of this
personality because i do think it saps
uh the confidence and and sort of
purpose and meaning of religious
commitment if you sort of say well this
is a book that has you know it's very
good guidelines and stuff but if you get
hit by a bus or something like that that
was just random right that was just you
know you can't control chaos
but
while you're alive you know
don't mix meat and milk or something i i
don't think that that works for me that
doesn't make sense i
for better or worse you know i i as a
theorist i like
total coherence and so maybe i gravitate
towards trying to
make it fit together
so you mentioned uh richard feynman and
i can't
i can't resist uh
hearkening back to his encounter
recounted in one of his books when he
met a young rabbi in seminary who asked
him is electricity fire
and uh apropos of your book and the fact
that you're a uh
a rabbi i'm going to ask you uh not to
pascan you know halacha but uh but could
you please speculate is electricity on
fire because it seems to me that the
reactions that are most endemically
human of human beings are not the fire
aspects you know that we produce energy
and we use energy and we excrete waste
entropy
but it's actually the you know process
of our three-pound supercomputer that's
running on chemical electricity
electrical signals and not uh fire
and that that was what makes us
fundamentally uniquely created in the
image of god so why is it uh why is it
that electricity is prohibited on the
sabbath in your opinion
um
jewish law it's it's a very interesting
and complex issue i mean i could talk
about in what i understand about the
history of
there are
decisors of jewish law who've chosen to
prohibit it
but i don't necessarily
think that there's uniform agreement
about that even among what you think of
perhaps as being very
uh
conservative or
religiously zealous thinkers in that
regard so um
for example
well yeah
but but i
there there are you know in the early
20th century for example
um
there were those who
while not permitting the use of
electricity even in
what is usually thought of as being the
very orthodox or perhaps ultra-orthodox
world
um who said
that
the risk of using it on chabad more has
to do with the uncertainty about what
other prohibited activities on shabbat
might be going on in a complex
contraption
and you don't really know
what that is but in principle there
could have been the idea of making like
a heck share like a kosher certification
for an electronic device on shabbat
because the actual electrical things
that are going on don't really fit the
bill there's different theories of what
you shouldn't be doing on shabbat
there's are you building something by
completing a circuit are you creating
something new when you turn on a light
is it fire are you lighting a fire
are you
completing the construction of something
i am not convinced actually personally
by any of these
i think that there are some electronic
contraptions where it probably is safer
to avoid using them um because of this
issue of how complicated they are and
not wanting to accidentally do something
that is definitely prohibited
but if you sort of boil things down to
a very simple device that is doing
something where you understand
how it's it's working like if you for
example have a you know an exposed
circuit with an open switch that you can
open and close and turning on an led
light
it starts to be much more possible to
argue that
there's nothing
problematic there although i think
clearly that's not the consensus in the
orthodox world um but i think it's a
discussion still worth continuing to
have because
uh it's such an expansive and constantly
changing field of technologies that it
doesn't really make sense
uh to
ban its
whole hog
just yeah no no pun intended um
just because
uh
at a certain point 100 years ago at this
point people
i think maybe were had the wrong
priorities in some sense and they were
just worried that it felt like it was
messing with what shabbat felt like and
it felt safer to just say just don't do
this but i don't think that that's
actually an acceptable basis for
apostating like to to make
um
[Music]
rulings in jewish law and if you try to
really base it in the fundamental
sources
that should be a continuing discussion i
would argue
very good continuing on about fire as it
is in the title of your book and the
central theme um i think that fire is
sort of the most
you know creative or destructive thing
the most like hashem that a god that a
human being can really do where you
transform you know utterly rearrange
the the structure of an item it produces
something new that never existed before
and it completely in its wake leaves
something utterly unrecognizable ashes
which were present perhaps within it
originally and just had to be liberated
and transformed
but there's only one other thing that
comes to mind which is not clear to me
it's prohibited on shabbos and that
would be you know thermonuclear fusion
or
something like that which is also kind
of a fiery associated process so maybe
it's gamma rays that that are the most
unique to the creative process but
are there other things you know uh
malacha forbidden work or aspects of
judaism that are particularly
impressive to you i've often found you
know little things of course i don't
believe you can prove the torah i don't
believe that there's any sense that you
can prove the existence of god and and
we could have a whole podcast about that
maybe we will when we're in person
someday but but the point being that um
you know it's sort of all encapsulating
is there anything else that you know you
could think about besides creating
another human life obviously where it's
ab initio you know it's really something
that never existed before in the case of
fire it's you took something that did
exist and created something you know
that's unrecognizable um are there other
things about the torah that are you know
impressive to you on a scientific
uh front um or am i uh you know am i
alone in sort of this appreciation of
the uniqueness of fire uh with the
possible exception as i said of
um of nuclear fusion which i don't think
is more it's relevant to people's lives
on a given any given shabbat well
there's sunlight you can cook with
sunlight on javette that's everyone
agrees that's totally fine if you can
you know you have some mirrors or
something and you want to fry an egg
using sunlight which is really the
product of nuclear fusion go right ahead
um so so maybe um
helmutic stages like nuclear fusion
but i don't know if they uh
have developed a power plant based on
that principle um
so
let's see i mean
there's a lot to unpack um
we were just mentioning but it's a
favorite topic of mine so i think
one of the things i'll just mention is
that
we tend to relate now to me
meaning the crafts that are prohibited
on shabbat on the jewish sabbath
introduced
in the talmud as
a list of positive things that were part
of the construction of the tabernacle in
the in the temple the mishkan the the
sort of tent with all of its different
elements and um
sort of building blocks that was
assembled in a very particular way um
that was the place you were supposed to
bring offerings in the temple
and
i actually personally think that that's
something that
i would like to see
rejuvenated in in judaism like we
learn about what we're not supposed to
do in shabbat because
the construction of the tabernacle was
halted on shabbat
but actually all of these crafts are
things we could be learning how to do
and
knowing how to do them
is a practical precondition for being
able to
operate a mishkan and and and keep more
of the mitzvot of the torah um and so i
think
i'm very much one who who doesn't
um
think that we should be kind of waiting
for a
magical solution to the existential
problems presented by the contradictions
of history and you know the the
enjoiners of the torah so it used to be
that it was inconceivable to think that
the jewish people could be in the land
of israel um and actually trying to have
a national life there because that was
centuries old and you know gone and it
was centuries before that would happen
again and i'm sure if you asked someone
in the 14th century oh yeah
don't we need to go and do that isn't
that part of what the tour is asking us
to do they just say no we have to wait
for you know a magical deliverance it
turns out that wasn't true and i think
that that also could be true
um
for the temple in jerusalem as well and
the point is you don't have to do that
tomorrow but you shouldn't sit on your
hands like if what you can do now is you
can learn how to weave and dye things
and pour molten metal and all the things
you need to do maybe that's something
that you know we should take more of an
interest in so that's an aside um i i
think that you know we we should
embrace
uh a positive aspect and not think of of
those things in the torah only is about
prohibition and sort of restriction
um
but i i also think that what's
interesting about
those
those crafts
is that they call your attention to the
whole idea of
what it is to create by combining
different elements into a whole
um and for example
one of the uh
ways that i've argued for reading the
opening passage of genesis
is you know it has this repetition and
it was evening and it was morning and it
was evening and it was morning you know
the seven days of creation um so it's
when it was evening it was morning so
erev
uh and boker also sound a lot like aurev
and bakar so
is a cow uh and what's interesting if
you look at
those themes and you can argue once you
hit on that there are other passages
that are clearly referent to you know
the creations uh the passage at the
beginning of genesis elsewhere in the
bible that are putting birds and cows
right next to each other in in something
called proshot elsewhere in the torah um
that the raven and the cow become
emblems for different kinds of motherly
nurturing right because the raven is the
bird who sort of picks up food in one
place and brings it over to you know
their children in another place to
nourish them so it's the transportation
of material from a to b um and then the
cow
will eat grass sort of standing in place
so to speak and turn it into milk and
nourish their young that way and i think
what's so interesting therefore is that
if you think about
any process of transforming
qualitatively one thing like grass into
milk which is another thing the idea of
chemical transmutation
on another scale what that actually is
is taking material and moving it from
one place to another right like it's the
rearrangement of atoms the same building
blocks are getting disassembled and
reassembled in a new way so qualitative
transformation at one scale
is the result of spatial relocation of
building blocks at another scale and you
know
you know could be uh
referent to that uh certainly insofar as
the different things that it's talking
about you know setting the sun and the
moon in the sky or you know separating
the water from the earth these are
different kinds of uh
spatial relocations that ultimately lead
perhaps to qualitative transformation on
other scales
so that was you know an idea that popped
into my head you know uh since you were
raising it and there are other things
that that you could look for as well i
really think that if you come to the
torah assuming
it knows everything you know and more
and you're looking for it to give you
its commentary on how
a servant of god should view the things
that you know about
then you can find
passages
that contain very deep insights uh
even about sort of what it is itself to
be a scientist like i think that the
story of joseph son of jacob um is a is
if you want a commentary on the whole
kind of idea of what it is to predict
the world scientifically and both what's
good about that and also what the sort
of dangers might be and sort of
idolizing that relationship to nature
very interesting uh yeah i often look to
when i'm you know i i personally have
more difficulty relating to prayer than
to study
and so i find it much more you know
distracting to study and read talmud and
my rabbis and and so forth and friends
um
but uh but i want to ask maybe a
conclusion because i know it's getting
late um i'd love to talk to you more but
maybe we'll do it in person i'd love to
talk to you about dust i study the
cosmic dust you study um you study
biological dust
uh the famous passage that the man
should have two pockets one when he is
haughty and one when he is uh feeling
low and basically one says i am but
dustin ashes and the other one says the
olam the universe was made for me
i'd love to to kind of uh get into that
someday i think that could be another
another long podcast but i guess the
last one uh that i want to talk about
today in light of the lateness of time
is uh
is is really this this notion of um you
know kind of
the
the the comments that i get as a
scientist you know from people who are
not anti-religious like frank wilczyk on
my podcast you know is
talking about the soul and and saying
you know the soul is this immaterial
thing that and sean carroll is also a
guest on the podcast is that you know
for these things to have any meaning
they have to interact and they don't
have any place in the standard model
lagrangia and you don't write down well
here's the solon and that's where that
comes in um so you know when i think
about and some of the arguments i think
are less less really impressive that
sean and others have made i know you've
been i guessed on his podcast as well
that you know you could as long as you
can think of a simpler explanation for
what god is uh or what the universe is
it could you create a simpler universe
why is the universe so profligate then
god is not a good theory um it doesn't
disprove god but it sort of takes away
some of the wind in his sails uh i don't
find those convincing to say you know
there's a hilbert space with one element
you know because you can always ask well
what created or who created the hilbert
space and the laws of mathematics they
came from our minds or interpreted in
our minds are they discovered are they
invented but i want to ask you you know
this consequence of materialism that
anything that's real can be measured and
i phrase this as
sensors and sensibility you know can we
build a sensory device
an augmented reality uh to augment our
senses
to detect something about
the existence of consciousness uh and
something special about humanity
or you know are we forever kind of
beholden to the mystery that we will
never be able to reveal
you know what makes conscious beings
conscious and what gives us free will
and what breathes fire into the
equations as the late great atheist
stephen hawking used to say although he
concluded the book
you know with uh if we can get a theory
of everything then we'll know the mind
of god uh some say that was to increase
book sales but but anyway uh rabbi i
want to ask you um
are we you know could you conceive of a
physical test or or something not even
in judaism in religion at all just
something to detect or augment our
senses as scientific apparatus do in my
lab and in
laboratories that you must be
familiar with is there any way
we can interact with the soul or
something incorporeal and corporeal uh
if that's uh if that's the right way to
phrase it so it's it's an interesting um
way to to bring things back to um
schrodinger because
i don't know if you
read the end of what is life but the
last chapter or a few chapters he starts
thinking about consciousness and ends up
getting into all this stuff with like
fedex philosophy from sort of ancient
indian texts
which i think is just it's such a great
example of how you know back back then
when you were a scientist you could just
you know write a paper and at the end be
like and then what do i think about
consciousness and you know it's hard to
get this kind of stuff through peer
review these days
um
nature doesn't look kindly
but um
i
i think that
the consciousness question
it's a very important one to bring up
because it exposes
the philosophical
mistakes
uh that are at the root of so many
scientific slash atheistic
sort of
trivializations of
uh religious attitudes because i think
at the end of the day
science as i mentioned before is trying
to focus on that which can be
idealized as objective and it seems the
same to you as it seems to me
and
it's a process that we can all do
together and we can find out certain
things about the world but it only
produces for us theories of what the
world seems like so to speak from the
outside right because that's what we can
talk about together
so you can do all sorts of science on
um
the behavior of
conscious beings and whether they report
themselves to be seeing red or whatever
but you never can do science on
subjective experience by definition you
can do science on how
living things act as though they have
subjective experience
and how they report about it and you can
try to do science on the complexity of
their behavior and impute or even kind
of define
it make a working definition in that
behavior of something you'd want to call
consciousness
nothing in that whole process
will ever touch
what we actually think we're talking
about when we say well i feel like i'm
sort of riding behind a pair of eyes and
the world exists
first and foremost as my own experience
and i think what that points to is that
really
all of these
scientists who you know
find it very easy to just say oh i think
you know god is a is a
useless theory or whatever
they they have they're only actually
willing to talk in terms that start with
assumptions that don't have to be made
and which are necessary in order to get
rolling with what you call the
scientific method in that whole process
and which it's like a commitment
made in some ways either out of
aesthetic desire or arbitrarily that no
one's willing to question the real
question if people want to start playing
that high stakes game
you have to roll it all the way back to
why do i think there's anything else
than my own experience right
what proves to me
that
there is a universe other than sort of
what i sense and what i feel
um and i'm not posing that question
because i you know the grand conclusion
here is you know oh actually
i'm just an i'm just like a sort of a
a sensory experience for you or you're
just a sensory experience for me
um but but i think that the point is
that kind of epistemic like radical
episcopal epistemic skepticism doesn't
have a scientific answer the answer is
i'll assume that away and then i'll
start doing science and let's let's not
worry about it but actually you have to
make essentially ideological commitments
in order to to get past it
and there are different ideological
systems that might deal with that in
different ways so the torah deals with
it in one way and and someone else might
deal with it differently
the reason i think that's important is
because what it what it means is
that
when you're asking about things like the
soul
if you want to relate to it as a measure
of things as an objectifier of things as
someone who's engaging in
examination of the world as a scientist
does
you're always going to be on the outside
of the thing sort of poking it and
seeing how it responds and that's fine
and you can make predictive theories and
there are i think
the kinds of progress that can be made
on
modeling
and describing and predicting
the sorts of behavior that seem more
conscious to us right like you can
describe with a model with many
parameters much more accurately
what the state of some complex conscious
behavior is
than if you do it with a few parameters
so i think we might make progress
using machine learning on you know
saying let's let's measure a thousand
quantities in the brain at once or a
billion quantities in the brain at once
and then we'll start to be able to kind
of learn what that means and and turn it
into certain kinds of predictions
but i think that anyone you know in
neuroscience in you know more broadly
you know talking
as scientists sort of do as
uh amateur philosophers from their
armchair i think usually unsuccessfully
um whenever someone talks about that as
sort of being what it would mean to
measure the soul
um they're making kind of a
philosophical category mistake they're
it's sort of a bait and switch
where they're they're passing
off the idea
that all there is is that which can be
scientized and therefore if there is
such a thing as what you'd call
um
the consciousness or the soul or all
these things they wanted to carry this
sort of zest of what we really mean when
we're talking about that which is has
more to do with subjective experience
but actually for it to be in the domain
of that which can be scientised and
objectified in fact i think they just
have a methodology that by definition
can't touch those things and if we want
to talk about those things then that we
need to roll things back further and and
talk about
you know how do we come into that
discussion
as
people who could share the same language
about it how do we come into that
discussion
and go beyond the individual experience
to like the shared experience of a
nation and amazingly
i think that's a huge part of what this
whole passage that is actually the focus
of
my book uh with regard to its
commentaries in the torah is about you
know
moses is alone in the desert
standing over a plant that is on fire
and he sees some crazy stuff right so if
i came to you and i said well i was in
the desert standing over an unidentified
plant that was on fire and i saw some
crazy things like i saw a stick turn
into a snake
so now that means i carry to you a
message from the creator of the world
you'd be like or maybe
it was just the plan i need to see a
psychiatrist i don't i don't think i
don't think that
the the torah is being accidental in
doing that it doesn't mean it was all
just a bad trip but what it's pointing
to
is that the problem is very hard one how
do you
bring into the common experience of a
whole nation the idea of
a relationship to the creator of the
world that starts with subjective
experience that's not an easy thing to
resolve
so
the resolution of it comes in stages and
comes in the path that moshe that moses
walks with the nation that he brings out
of egypt
and it starts with the signs that are
given to him and i don't even talk about
this aspect of it at all in the book but
i think the first point is the staff
that turns into a snake it's exactly
about this question about the choice of
your frame you put on experience
you have one object right it's a staff
and it turns into not an elephant and
not a mouse it turns into the animal
that looks the most like a staff it
turns into a serpent
and the point there
is that this is really about two
different interpretive frames laid on
the same experience it could be that you
look at it as an inanimate
measuring object or measurable object
kind of the physicist's way of looking
at the world that it's a collection of
inanimate objects that stick together or
that you can
um describe predictably one end does
what you make it what you want it to do
when you push on the other end or maybe
it's a serpent which is not just like a
living thing it's the talking thing
right it's the talking animal the nahash
the serpent from the garden of eden so
it's it's the same experience of the
world and you can either relate to it
like a prophet with his hair on fire
seeing sort of voices and messages or
you can relate to it as
you know the inanimate dust um that
we're all composed of where a physicist
would say there's no difference between
you and a table or you in a pile of
ashes
um and and you can't dispense with
either of those
you need both of those ways of looking
at the world
and i find it very interesting that
later on uh
the zealot uh featured prominently in
this week's parsha pinkhat because he uh
he uses a staff-like object
to carry out the uh the will of god
zealously but we won't get into why he
did that uh because it's late there and
uh and i really enjoyed this
conversation uh rabbi jeremy i did as
well just a phenomenal mind and i do
hope we can meet in person and maybe
uh and maybe share a shabbat together or
something like this this would be
wonderful for me and on behalf of all my
guests all my guests all my listeners
and all my viewers on youtube dr brian
keating there and into the impossible on
all podcast channels we thank you so
much you're one of my most requested
guests i want to thank david klinghoffer
of discovery institute for putting us
together and i look forward to many many
more
fruitful conversations together thank
you so much rabbi
shabbat shalom let me be the first to
wish you shabbat shalom
take care thank you very much
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]